aujourd'hui il est clair que normal le
landais avec tout ce qu'on entend il
bénéficiait de complicités oui c'est
probable c'est à dire que ce qu'on
essaie de faire au travers de notre
travail avec holly et toute l'équipe de
l'envers des affaires ses 10 rebonds
on nous présente souvent des personnes
comme étant des prêts de prédateurs
isolé c'est donc par exemple du trou
nous a dit c'est un prédateur isolé
alors que maintenant il est avéré que
produit tout évidemment il y avait un
réseau derrière et puis il se trouve que
je viens chez vous à balances ton post
un soir et je vois ce garçon il est avec
céline fournirait mon ami d'acteurs et
là il commence à partir un peu en vrille
il commence à dire en france cassé il
fournirait montre une lettre en disant
voilà monsieur fourniret avait un
vénérable maître d'une loge franc
maçonne je tombe de ma chaise comme
naulleau qui étaient là comme il y avait
en moi que c'est tout et j'attrape au
lit après j'ai dit c'est quoi ces
conneries pour ces des commandes de
machines spéciales pour son laboratoire
insuffisamment étrange et mystérieux
pour que je lui dise baoli vasif l
enquête donc il a travaillé pendant cinq
mois et il a sorti donc ce qu'on voit à
la une de notre voisine qui se cache
derrière voilà et l'ogre des arbres et
on découvre un fournirait mais alors
qu'est pas du tout un prédateur
solitaire faut savoir qu'il a commencé
en 66 terminée en 2003 quand il a été
arrêté
entre temps quelques années de prison un
casier judiciaire blanchi et puis le
plus incroyable c'est qui se vantait de
franc maçonnerie et on est que ali a
retrouvé ce vénérable maître qui répond
à l'interview interview qui dit
qu'effectivement ils ont soutenu
financièrement michel fourniret
ce qui est quand même absolument fou et
pour nordahl le landais aujourd'hui on
serait dans le même cas oui et
d'ailleurs ce que normal le landais
quand il dit je ne suis qu'un maillon le
dernier maillon de la chaîne c'est ce
qui veut dire ah oui mais encore une
fois il ya des similitudes avec le faire
fournirait c'est encore du monde il ya
un ancien soldat d'accord et est donc
oui valérie non moi j'aurais posé une
question à karl parce que tu sais
exactement ce qu'on va composer car on
va te parler de la sphère patrice alègre
on va te dire que tu vois des réseaux
partout une première fois ça a déjà
coûté la vie à un homme parce que body
son départ au mit et là elle est là on a
le sentiment que turque alcan quelque
sorte une somme de jeudi d
2 nota alors qu'ils utiliseraient des
pions et qui permet d' ambitieux et
l'armée je veux dire l'argent quand
j'entends tout à fait et d'ailleurs j'ai
personnellement écrit les dessous de
l'affairé allègre dans le magazine pour
donner ma version des choses parce que
finalement j'ai jamais plus la donne est
donc soit on rentre buyster de baudis
mais en gros baudis et il torturait pas
d'enfants mais baudis a été un peu
libertin il a le droit tu vois moi j'ai
pas faire du jugement moral sur la vie
de ma mère est ce ton ce soit là
fernando secondes et après a été pris
dans une sorte de piège qu'elle en
essayant d'imaginer en reparler
politique aussi était en plus de son
bord et des personnes qui
malheureusement violet et torturer des
enfants dont il ne faisait pas partie
mais le fait de lâcher dans le jeu est
lâché un nom aussi prestigieux que
dominique baudis a fait exploser la
sphère en vol
ça a été parfaitement réussie ensuite
mettez en cause l'armée là s'il vous
plaît car et qu'on reste sur le sujet
oui oui savourer que la la vous mettez
en cause quoi vous mettez en cause
l'armée parce que si vous dit arrêtez
pas dire 500 da non moi je mets en cause
globale le landais d'accord et ses amis
qui c'est qui ces amis sont des gens qui
sont toujours libres comme l'air et qui
pour l'instant ne sont pas inquiétés par
la justice
mais d'après ce qu'on m'a dit il
pourrait bientôt y avoir des
interpellations
en tout cas je précise que pour la faire
de l' incendie de la gendarmerie de
grenoble dans laquelle des scellés de la
ferme à hélices ont brûlé il n'a eu
aucune interpellation
oui et ça vous est très intéressant et
je voyais mon brave qu'elle dit gérard
collomb ah oui vous avez la vidéo
d'ailleurs regardez c'est passé comme
une lettre à la poste c'est scandaleux
gardé par exemple sur
ça veut dire que ce sont les gendarmes
qui sont en train d'étudier
la disparition de la petite maelys qui
sont empêchés dans leur travail
nous avons des forces considérables 300
personnes qui enquête sur cette affaire
donc laissons travailler celles et ceux
qui veulent mettre fin aux disparitions
d'enfants
ça c'est très important parce que on a
dit c'est un groupe anarchiste
libertaire et même féministes qui avait
mis le feu à la gendarmerie mais il
s'avère qu'on n'a jamais retrouvé ce
groupe féministe et libertaire en
revanche les scellés de la faire maëlys
le landais ont disparu là c'est un fait
regarde ça ouais je pense moi j'ai géré
qu énormément de témoignages inédits et
je pense avoir de quoi il retourne et
celle que je vous un vrai rêve elle
invitera à découvrir très bientôt et
noirs dan le landais il avait été
incarcéré à grenoble à la prison de la
barse et là il aurait fait une rencontre
déterminante d'après ce que me dit un
ancien policier qui lui-même en
apprenant que nordahl les landais
avaient croisé la route banal indique de
la police en lien avec des ripoux jeu
désolé de le dire mais c'est digne d'un
film d'olivier marchal mais c'est
malheureusement la réalité
ce flic en question a fait un
signalement qui est resté lettre morte
et qu'il n'y a eu aucune suite
ça veut dire que depuis longtemps c'est
moi même il ya des gens qui savent que
cette histoire de nandan le landais
n'est pas celle qu'on a présenté adacore
dépêchés dans ses commanditaires bien
sûr mais je dirais d'en parler avant
très peu il ya quatre ans d'enquêté vous
vous dites que ces quatre ans elles sont
enquêtés il ya au départ on enquête sur
40 disparition personnes ils réduisent à
14 on sait pas très bien pourquoi parce
que quand on regarde dans les détails on
se rend compte que c'est un peu au petit
bonheur la chance que parfois ils ont
bordé téléphone de le landais tel jour
mais pas le lendemain ça peut être le
lendemain tu vois si il ya aussi un
problème de coût financier et il ya
autour de l'hollandais une espèce
d'excitation mais finalement pour nous
le présenter en prédateur solitaire et
nous on est là pour vous dire de ce
qu'on a enquêté on est en train
d'enquêter on continue en ce moment mais
on ressent pas un prédateur solitaire
élus tous les dans les premiers jours du
mois c'est le rideau pour mener leurs
projets c'est ce qu'on ressent également
et c'est ce qu'il est en train de dire
comment ça dit elle maillon de la
vilaine que lui il exécutait des ordres
sur des en train de laisser entendre un
joli profit de la présence de leurs
pauvres voilà bien souligné le fait que
le mentor de nordahl de landes et voilà
qu'on ne va pas citer celui qui a
agressé sexuellement la fille de l'or là
ont mené durant ce fameux soir au même
endroit où est décédé ou a été assassiné
le caporal noyer trajet ce que c'est un
endroit où ils avaient leurs habitudes
on parle de crime organisé un le trajet
de crime organisé on parle on parle en
réalité de deux personnes qui sont
capables de vente de la drogue ou des
voitures volées ou malheureusement des
mineurs
et dans le cas de maëlys on est en train
de se poser la question de dire bon
finalement maëlys correspond pas
exactement au type de personne car on
vit forcément de viol et monsieur le
landais est-ce que c'est pas une
commande
il avait agressé sexuellement ses
cousines 6 à 14 ans et sexuellement il
avait fait des photos après en finale et
où il avait à toucher il avait quand
même chez photo n'oublie pas que les
photos se vendent n'oublie pas que par
exemple un brin de foot lumière quatre
cent mille personnes sont tombées
vous avez suivi en adjani à réseaux
pédocriminels et ben c'est des vrais
enfants c'est pas des enfants plastique
600 sont là vous pensez qu normal le
landais ya un très gros réseau derrière
moi je sais moi je parle veux pas parler
de réseau je préfère parler crime
organisé
aujourd'hui on en 2021 on peut pas dire
que la mafia ça n'existe pas donc je
peux vous dire dans ce fameux club de
boxe de challes-les-eaux il ya des noms
du grand banditisme qui sont cités et
dans le grand banditisme en existe dans
ce même club une des dames qui entraîné
est venu me rencontrer en pleurant sur
mon épaule et en me disant oh c'est
horrible ce qui a été fait c'est
horrible ce qui a été fait oui
effectivement
et là elle me dit ah moins mon mari qui
est parti en prison pour avoir violé ma
fille dont elle aurait accouché sous x
gilles verdez alors faut parler de crime
organisé mais en vous entendant on a
l'impression quand même que les enquêtes
elles mêmes ont été étouffées c'est ça
dont crime organisé ou avec selon vous
des complicités au niveau des enquêteurs
et peut-être des gendarmes qui ont mené
les enquêtes
il ya beaucoup de cas de destruction de
preuves riorges hisse au fil de mon
enquête j'ai des témoignages édifiants
devant l'un d'eux ne faut pas
généraliser à venir plus est dans lé
nord grande majorité et les services de
tennis et les services de gendarmerie et
les magistrats font leur boulot on dit
qu'on décale il arrive qu'ils aient
quelques personnes un peu habitué des
coups de pression on dit que plus
personne ne parle dans ce dossier vous
avez reçu des coups de pression ou moi
j'ai reçu un coup de pression oui j'ai
eu un j'ai eu un contrôle
à l'époque j'ai eu un contrôle de
répression et je me suis rendu compte
que la personne qui m'a fait envoyer le
contrôle était le voyage le voisin de
palier de l'agresseur sexuel de ma fille
d'accord et je suis car bien que
personne ne parle dans cette affaire on
a l'impression que plus personne ne
parlait pas non moi j'en ai fait parler
beaucoup et vous avez quand ça sortira
moi j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup de
témoignages un climat de menaces quand
même avoir mon nom dans cette affaire
oui oui j'ai parlé avec des gens qui
craignent pour leurs leurs jours qui ont
été menacés qui ont reçu des gros coup
de pression jusqu'à suivre certaines
personnes devant le commissariat le jour
de l'audition pour leur dire attention à
ce que tu veux dire moi je sais même
qu'à un proche de le landais qui a dit
alors je dirai pas qui pour l'instant
mais qui a dit de toute façon normal
s'il parle on lui donnera un cachet
magique
ah ouais je vais entre guillemets un
autant c'est que dalle de l'andeva
donner des noms pensée faut pas qu'un
ordre le landais suite à son arrestation
il ya des son frère la première
déclaration qu'il a faite son frère
semaine il a dit mon frère protège des
protège des complices suite à ça il ya
des tags qu'elles sont apparues dans la
ville où vivaient une balance et il a
été tabassé lui et sa mère lorsqu'il est
interrogé
le landais ne reconnaît pas de viol sur
maëlys et explique même sa mort en
disant c'est un accident
il s'est mis à crier je lui ai mis une
claque trop forte elle est morte c'est
un ancien militaire et les super barak
et il fait de la boxe
je ne sais tout à fait crédible ou
est-ce qu'il allait avec cette petite et
15 est-ce que vous pensez que normal le
landais peut balancer des noms
ça dépend de la peine qui prendra et ça
dépend des relations qui va avoir avec
les autres détenus en prison
d'accord moissac il a été protégé par un
bâton en prison quand il était là mars
et entre temps ce type est déjà tombé
pour corruption
il pourra jamais ressortir ce nordahl le
landais mais aussi que l'agresseur ne
sait jamais
et reste aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on voit
que patrice alègre demande à sortir je
vois que j'ai maintenant demande à
sortir
il est tout à fait possible que dans 22
ans il ressort michelle martin cette
version selon laquelle la demande et
aurait eu des complices voire un mentor
elle est affirmé par lui-même à son
procès est ce que c'est pas une
stratégie de sa part qui amoindrit sa
responsabilité
william honneur sa peine oui mais on est
dans le vrai monde enquêtant baril est à
venir le témoignage de l'homme ne marche
pas de m'arriver
ça veut dire qu'on va aller chercher
l'or c'est une actrice et c'est faux or
lors elle est vraiment venu en ami de là
bas at home et la faillite y acheter non
j'ai un jugement
ge voilà je veux dire j'ai il ya quatre
gamine qui ont été agressés ça commence
en 2008 sa fille née en 2010 parce que
j'ai fait exploser la faire l'agresseur
de ma fille c'est quand même mis à
genoux devant ma fille ce soir là en lui
demandant de ne pas déposer plainte on
m'a mis la pression pour je ne dépose
pas plainte
et aujourd'hui si je suis à visage
découvert c'est parce que j'ai quatre
petites filles et que je n'ai pas
j'aimerais et je souhaite que tous les
parents et grands-parents de du monde
entier n'est pas à vivre cette chose là
et je pense énormément aux parents de
miley chez ankama ligue ou villa qui lui
aussi a disparu en 2012 je pense à
toutes ces personnes que je côtoie et
moi j'ai de la chance parce que ma fille
est rentrée à la maison vivante mais
est-ce que j'aurais pas pu être à la
place des parents de miley ce geste
dernière question au lit et équins vous
pensez on a l'impression que dans cette
affaire on veut dire que une protection
autour de deux de ces personnes
elle viendrait d'où cette protection ccc
voilà ces profs qui sont cachés c'est un
vrai don de ses amis de ses connections
haut mais ces connexions 20 avait le
bras long non mais donc des connexions
très très haut placée haut placées pas
forcément bon pour saper oblige normal
se balader avec un gyrophare et un
bracelet de policiers mais c'est une
série de réponses et c'est pas il se
plonge dans la mecque des gens derrière
macao placés du grand banditisme
c'est avant tout un dealer de cap
politique aussi politiques parfois être
politique
j'ai vu passer en nombre bah oui vous
avez vu passé politique
la salle de boxe en question après la
condamnation
vers la mairie a continué en octobre et
c'est ça oui alors après la après la
sphère du moment où ils avaient une
interdiction d'exercer j'ai pas compris
qu'on puisse le laisser aller j'avais
prévenu les autres entraîneurs qui ont
continué et j'ai des photos et gégé
demander une autorisation à la mairie de
faire rentrer un huissier de justice de
façon à faire constater qu'il était là
bas parce que je savais qu'il était là
bas et j'ai eu un refus de la mairie en
me disant que j'étais malade et que
j'étais dans la douleur et qu'il fallait
que je me calme
je suis allé à la gendarmerie à l'époque
de challes les eaux où j'ai été reçue
comme une paria vraiment hyper mal reçue
je suis partie en leur disant j'écrirai
plus haut il a fallu que j'écrive
beaucoup plus haut pour être recontactés
par des gens d'un petit là et ont été
très corrects à challes-les-eaux cette
fois ci en me disant mais on ne comprend
pas je voudrais que je voudrais que en
deux secondes
holy nous raconte une ex fiancé 2
nordahl qui est allé une semaine avant
la disparition de maylis témoigner à la
gendarmerie raconte elle s'était
présentée à la gendarmerie après que
nordland elle est menacée et une fois
arrivé là bas
les gendarmes auront tout bonnement
refusé de prendre sa plainte
on lui dira en prétextant que nordahl
c'est un mec bien ça aurait être évitée
à travers dit qu'on connaît la
disparition de la petite miley tire bien
vous savez pour l'or l'expertisé médias
qu'une médico légal il lui a été refusée
à sa fille pour déterminer s'il y avait
un